[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas las más importantes
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 a continuación les presento algunos
de los temas que vamos a tratar en esta
edición
fue destacado a lo largo de esta semana
el apoyo que dio el gobierno de eeuu a
la posibilidad de liberar las patentes
de las vacunas contra el hobby 19 al
menos de manera temporal para impulsar
la vacunación a nivel mundial el debate
quedó sobre la mesa
eeuu españa francia y otros países del
mundo respaldaron la idea alemania pidió
debatir el tema mientras que el reino
unido suiza y japón rechazaron
tajantemente por temas de propiedad
intelectual abordaremos este tema desde
diferentes ángulos también la
administración federal de alimentos de
eeuu la fd indicó que está estudiando la
posibilidad de comenzar a vacunar a
adolescentes la misma medida está siendo
evaluada también en uruguay en el
extremo sur del continente lo cierto es
que el número de personas jóvenes
hospitalizadas con kobe 19 ha ido en
aumento en los últimos días y de ahí la
preocupación para poderles garantizar a
este grupo de la población una
protección contra el virus y en nuestra
consulta con el doctor pérez que se las
quedamos debiendo del programa pasado
por un tema técnico nuestro
científico de france 24 hablaremos no
solamente del tema de las patentes sino
de otras vacunas que podrían salir al
mercado en las próximas semanas
hablaremos también de la variante de la
india que ya comienza a dispersarse por
el planeta y veremos en detalle los
resultados de un estudio que habla sobre
la posibilidad de vacunar a las mujeres
que están gestando en unos minutos vamos
a conversar entonces sobre este tema
pues ya lo avanzaba en los titulares en
el sumario avanza el debate a nivel
internacional sobre la liberación de las
patentes de las vacunas contra el jove
19 las farmacéuticas que amasan fortunas
con la producción de las vacunas están
en contra de esta propuesta la unión
europea se mostró a favor de hacer una
discusión sobre este tema francia-españa
y también el vaticano dieron el visto
bueno a la propuesta mientras que
alemania
cree que la propiedad intelectual debe
protegerse y por eso prefirió quedarse
de lado y debatir sobre esta propuesta
también eeuu y la organización mundial
de la salud se mostraron a favor la
medida sin embargo no va a solucionar
las cosas
desde dosis al tiempo que eso generaría
un incremento en la demanda de
suministros para los insumos requeridos
para la fabricación de estas vacunas
veamos
el debate sobre hacer de la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 un bien común se
calienta en el momento en que las
farmacéuticas publican ganancias récord
en el primer trimestre de 2021 facer
ingreso 3 mil millones y medio de
dólares para el global anual
la farmacéutica prevé 26 mil millones
mientras que el laboratorio moderna hace
una previsión de 18.000 millones de
dólares volúmenes de negocio que
supondrían un margen de beneficios
brutos de entre el 25 y el 30 por ciento
ante la perspectiva de una suspensión de
las patentes sobre las vacunas el lobby
farmacéutico no tardó en reaccionar la
decisión de la administración de eeuu de
apoyar una extensión de la patente para
las vacunas cobit 19 es decepcionante
como hemos reiterado una extensión es la
respuesta simple pero incorrecta a un
problema complejo
las farmacéuticas alegan que suspender
las patentes conllevaría una escasez
mundial de las materias primeras
necesarias para fabricar las vacunas
dicen tener una disminución de la
calidad del fármaco y opinan que sin el
aliciente de los beneficios cae la
innovación la suspensión de las patentes
fue reclamada por india y sudáfrica y la
petición cuenta con el apoyo de eeuu
mientras que la unión europea se declara
abierta a discutirla pero es necesario
el consenso de los 164 miembros de la
organización mundial del comercio para
aprobar la medida mientras que en eeuu
más del 30 por ciento de la población
está completamente vacunada en sudáfrica
esta cifra no llega al 1%
vamos a hablar de este y otros temas con
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
nueva york que en eeuu mamen sala con
quien también vamos a actualizar la
situación en ese país norteamericano
hola mamá y gracias por acompañarnos hoy
en el programa y que más detalles se han
conocido sobre esta posición que tiene
el gobierno del presidente yo byd en
deliberar y aprobar esta esta propuesta
liberar las patentes de las vacunas para
impulsar la vacunación en otros países
si este anuncio del presidente de yoga
idem refleja que está cediendo a la
presión internacional y también a la
presión de muchos de sus colegas
demócratas que hace tiempo que le piden
que libere las patentes de las vacunas
sobre todo en un momento en el que
países en vías de desarrollo como india
o sudáfrica están siendo realmente
castigados por la pandemia que significa
realmente liberar a estas patentes pues
bien básicamente es abrir las puertas a
los secretos de las empresas
farmacéuticas estadounidenses a empresas
de todo el mundo así que como en todas
las situaciones hay gente a favor y hay
gente en contra en un lado están los
activistas que defienden que la
situación es excepcional y como tal hay
que tomar medidas excepcionales además
piden que esta liberación de las
patentes vaya también acompañada de una
transferencia de información es decir
que los dueños de estas patentes
faciliten también información personal y
todo lo que tenga que ver con la parte
tecnológica para poder replicar estas
vacunas en el otro lado están las
empresas farmacéuticas que no han
recibido nada bien la noticia aseguran
que esto no va
mejorar la situación es más lo va a
empeorar va a hacer todavía más tensa
esa cadena de suministro que hay ahora y
además va a dar lugar a que se produzcan
réplicas falsificadas en el mercado
negro de estas vacunas que podría ser
realmente peligroso bam en el gobierno
del estado de nueva york
avaló que las personas que vayan a este
estado ya la ciudad de nueva york por
turismo pueden vacunarse allí contra el
cubil 19 incluso el gobierno está
estudiando la posibilidad que a los
turistas que deseen aplicarse la
inmunización reciban la vacuna de
johnson y johnson que es de una sola
dosis quien más se conoce sobre este
tema porque una gran cantidad de
latinoamericanos están llegando a eeuu
para recibir las vacunas principalmente
a miami o el sur de la florida
si hablamos de lo que se conoce ya como
turismo de vacuna kobe 19 y es un
fenómeno que cada vez crece más para que
os hagáis una idea la agencia mexicana
de viajes asegura que ya hay cerca de 50
empresas allí que están ofreciendo el
paquete de viaje y vacuna por cerca de
1000 dólares
este fenómeno está un poquito rozando la
línea de la legalidad porque en
principio para vacunarse contra él comí
19 en eeuu es necesario ser ciudadano o
residente permanente pero sí que es
verdad que hay algunos estados donde
esto no se está controlando como por
ejemplo texas luisiana o arizona hay que
decir que esto está ocurriendo también
porque hay muchos excedentes de dosis ya
que la población local no está confiando
en las vacunas así que cada vez son más
las personas que viajan a eeuu y
aprovechan para vacunarse sobre todo
muchas de ellas procedentes de
latinoamérica que no tienen prohibida la
entrada a eeuu en este momento como por
ejemplo si lo tienen los europeos los de
la zona
jane en uno de los estados que podría
una de las ciudades que podría sumarse a
este fenómeno en los próximos días es
nueva york su alcalde anunció esta
semana que pretende atraer al turismo
ofreciendo una vacuna de johnson and
johnson que es de tan sólo una
aplicación a todos aquellos visitantes
que se acerquen a la gran manzana no
deja de ser atractivo para los
latinoamericanos y era eeuu a vacunarse
a aquellos que tienen los recursos
porque los planes de vacunación en la
región avanzan muy lentamente y mamen
life that también fue destacado a lo
largo de esta semana porque indicó que
está estudiando la posibilidad de
comenzar a vacunar a los adolescentes en
eeuu para así poder garantizar una
cobertura total de la sociedad de eeuu
desde los mayores hasta los más pequeños
cómo va eso
si es un paso importante santiago en la
lucha contra la pandemia
la empresa pzifer asegura que ya casi ha
terminado los ensayos en los niños
menores de 11 años y pretende pedir la
autorización del uso de su vacuna en
niños de entre 1 y 11 años en el mes de
septiembre pero es que además la semana
que viene también pretende pedir a la
agencia del medicamento estadounidense a
la fd al que autorice el uso de su
vacuna en niños de entre 12 y 15 años
dice que tan pronto como tenga esa
aprobación podría distribuir
inmediatamente 20 mil dosis en farmacias
en todo el país para que os hagáis una
idea ahora mismo en eeuu se han aplicado
ya 255 millones de dosis y el 50% de
ellas son de facer con un 33,4 por
ciento de la población estadounidense
completamente inmunizada contra el cob y
19 valen muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde eeuu dándonos
detalles de la situación allí vamos a
retomar entonces el tema de la
liberación de las
de las vacunas contra el cob y 19 esta
propuesta ha generado todo tipo de
discrepancias en la comunidad
internacional cuando la unidad es
fundamental para hacer frente a la
pandemia que no da tregua en ninguna
parte en ningún rincón del planeta a
favor de la liberación de las patentes
se mostraron ya lo decíamos eeuu también
españa francia india y sudáfrica en
contra están el reino unido alemania
suiza y japón que pusieron en marcha el
lobby farmacéutico por miedo a la
escasez de materias primas al menos eso
argumentaron el debate llega justo
cuando las farmacéuticas están
obteniendo cifras récords de ventas y
también de volumen de negocios sin
precedentes la unión europea por su
parte se mostró abierta a debatir entre
los 27 países y también la comunidad
internacional sobre este tema
y está con nosotros el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez infectólogo y asesor
científico de france 24 con quien vamos
a conversar sobre varios temas que
tenemos en la agenda para resolver
varias dudas aclarar algunas preguntas
que tenemos por parte de nuestros
televidentes doctor gracias por estar
con nosotros como siempre un placer
saludarlo hoy sin problemas técnicos hoy
con usted aquí listo para responder las
preguntas y es posible que esta
liberación de las vacunas que tanto
podría ayudar a la vacunación a nivel
mundial sea posible llegar a eso la
liberación de las patentes usted la ve
viable posible
santiago hola buenas noches miren en la
liberación de las patentes es un proceso
que se hace en situaciones de emergencia
como las que estamos viviendo y lo que
se necesita realmente es acceso a las
vacunas universalmente las patentes no
son si se libere es la parte que no es
que exclusivamente todos los países
vayan a empezar a producir hay una
necesidad hay una complejidad industrial
que se requiere para la producción de
las vacunas pero es un paso para
permitir que haya mayor oferta en países
y en industrias que tienen la capacidad
para desarrollarla nosotros como
comunidad médica y muchos somos voceros
de que si debe haber una liberación de
las patentes y hacer transferencia a la
tecnología para que haya equidad en las
vacunas aquí el problema no es
desarrollar una vacuna es que sea
equitativa para la humanidad
hablemos ahora de la vacuna curva que
está en camino está bastante avanzada en
sus fases de investigación es una vacuna
alemana que saben ustedes sobre esta
fase de estudios y que saben de esta
vacuna y de su desarrollo doctor
esta va a ser sometida ya con sus
estudios en las próximas semanas para su
aprobación en la emea y posteriormente
en la fea y cuando se somete es porque
los resultados son prometedores y
esperan pues que se pueda comercializar
prontamente esta es una una que también
es de rn a símil y fue similar a facer y
moderna en su casa matriz es en alemania
y es muy interesante porque tiene menor
exigencia en la cadena de frío eso
quiere decir que va a ser mucho más
fácil su logística para distribución y
además de eso esta vacuna entre hacer
parte de estas vacunas herreña que han
tenido un gran impacto en la reducción
de las hospitalizaciones y de la
mortalidad entonces necesitamos una
nueva vacuna y muy probablemente en un
par de semanas ya tengamos esta vacuna
disponible y tiene estudios en américa
latina en varios países de américa
latina se han desarrollado los estudios
del club entonces la esperamos con
ansias en unas semanas podríamos estar
tanto esta noticia doctor y así alemania
entonces tendría si no estoy mal dos
vacunas ya en el mercado
contra el co bit 19 otro de los temas
que teníamos en la agenda doctor
pendiente para conversar con usted es la
variante de la india está generando
temor sobre todo en los países asiáticos
que tienen frontera con india dado el
caso que se está presentando allí de una
saturación completo del sistema y un
aumento muy rápido de los casos de kobe
19 que ha provocado que el gobierno no
tenga capacidad para actuar y responder
ante la situación 17 países en el mundo
ya han registrado algunos casos de ellos
algunos latinoamericanos que luego los
vamos a mencionar que se sabe de esta
variante
esta variante es mucho más contagiosa
que decir que lo que hablamos nosotros
que haya un periodo de diez o quince
minutos para transmitir la enfermedad
cuando la gente no usa los medios de
protección aquí son cuestión de muy
pocos minutos y es mucho más contagiosa
su transmisión al ser mucho más
contagiosa aumenta el número de
infectados y al aumentar el número de
infectados el porcentaje que se
hospitaliza pues es mucho más grande
hemos visto que es una enfermedad más
agresiva y se suma a los determinantes
sociales que hay en la india y a la
fragilidad de los sistemas de salud que
no son capaces de responder a una alta
demanda de pacientes y creo que no es un
problema del día sino es un problema
universal pero se ha magnificado en la
vida por su densidad en la población
afecta mucho a personas jóvenes no
necesariamente con comorbilidades alta
contagiosidad y sin duda es una nueva
amenaza también en esta pandemia que es
la pandemia de los linajes
doctor y para cerrar esta consulta le
pregunto por un estudio publicado hace
un par de semanas que daba cuenta de los
resultados de una investigación muy
extensa que se hizo en mujeres
embarazadas y la conclusión de este
informe es que tal parece que las
mujeres embarazadas pueden recibir
algunas de las vacunas contra el kobe 19
ampliemos más sobre este tema
es muy interesante porque es una buena
noticia en medio de todo estas malas
noticias que hemos tenido este par de
semanas porque se vacunar un gran grupo
de mujeres embarazadas más de 30 mil
mujeres embarazadas con las vacunas de
rn y se encontró que el riesgo era
similar al de la población no no
gestante y eso indica la seguridad
también en la población embaraza eso va
a ser muy importante porque un paso
adicional es la vacunación de
adolescentes pero también involucrar las
vacunas en las mujeres embarazadas con
la ventaja que los anticuerpos es decir
las defensas se pueden transmitir al
bebé y se puede el binomio madre-hijo
proteger del coi desigual es una noticia
alentadora es una noticia registrada en
en las revistas científicas y que en un
par de semanas también esperamos que ya
haya la recomendación no solamente para
los adolescentes tienen las mujeres
envasadas que se va a poner con estas
vacunas de rn a mensaje doctor pues
cerramos con esta noticia positiva lo
más seguro es que en un par de semanas
estamos profundizando en este tema
cuando cuando ya haya un poco más
conocimiento sobre este estudio médico
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en france 24 como siempre un
gusto y bueno aquí está para resolver
algunas de las preguntas de los
televidentes y preguntas que nos surgen
también a nosotros los periodistas ahora
veamos las cifras de cómo está avanzando
el contagio de coronavirus en el mundo
la emergencia sigue hay que seguir
cuidándose en el mundo contabilizan ya
156 millones 233 mil casos o más de
ellos
han fallecido hasta el momento 19 de
kobe 19 3 millones 259 mil personas los
recuperados ya alcanzan los 92 millones
400 mil personas mientras que las dosis
inoculadas es decir las personas que
hayan recibido una o dos dosis de alguna
de las vacunas ya se cuentan por 625
millones de personas los países más
afectados en su estricto orden siguen
siendo eeuu india brasil francia y entra
en este top 5 turquía
y vamos ahora está méxico vamos a
conocer cómo está la situación en este
país que cuenta ya con 2.3 millones de
casos concretos de kobe 19 tal parece de
cierta forma en méxico está escapando un
poco de ese momento crítico que están
viviendo otros países latinoamericanos
la mayoría digamos están en suramérica
pero méxico llama la atención por eso
vamos a saludar a mario carbón es
nuestro corresponsal permanente allí en
la ciudad de mexico para conocer más
detalles de mario ya fueron reportados
allí los primeros casos de la variante
india que hace unos minutos estábamos
hablando de sus características que se
sabe de estos casos
así es fue el pasado 2 de mayo cuando se
identificó el primer caso de la
presencia de esta variante india de
coronavirus en el estado de san luís
potosí en la zona centro del país se
trata de un paciente de 40 años y se
presume que el contagio pudo haberse
originado tras haber tenido contacto con
un grupo de extranjeros que vino a una
capacitación laboral a ese estado y
entre ellos pues había un residente de
la india a la fecha hay 34 casos
posiblemente asociados a esta variante
india de covite sin embargo solamente
uno este que te refiero es el que se ha
identificado plenamente y confirmado en
el instituto nacional de referencia
epidemiológica y el resto sigue aún en
estudio de acuerdo con las autoridades
sanitarias del país y según la o ms se
trata de una variante de interés más no
de preocupación habrá que ver los
resultados de los otros casos y si no
hay presencia en otros estados de la
república
yo aprovecho para preguntarle cuál es la
situación actual en méxico en cuanto a
hospitalizaciones personas fallecidas
contagiados y ocupación de las salas de
cuidado intensivo cómo está la situación
allí
por la situación actual es de una
disponibilidad de camas de
hospitalización superior en el 84%
estamos muy lejos de cuando tuvimos la
crisis de falta de camas de hospital y
la vacunación avanza el pasado 5 de mayo
se alcanzó una cifra récord de
aplicación de dosis en un solo día con
más de 600 4.000 dosis aplicadas va
actualmente el 10 por ciento de la
población ya vacunadas son poco más de
13 millones de mexicanos los que han
recibido al menos su primera dosis y
cerca de 9 millones que tienen ya su
esquema completo es decir las dos dosis
méxico se ubica en el lugar número 12 en
el ranking de países que más vacunas han
recibido y han aplicado actualmente
estamos en el rango de edad de 50 59
años la población que está siendo
vacunada y también se ha comenzado a
inocular a los maestros van más de
1.300.000 integrantes del personal
educativo que han sido inoculados
-mario interesante e interesante la
situación actual en méxico y eso me
lleva a preguntarle porque parece que
este país está logrando escapar de ese
pico que está viviendo y suramérica
principalmente o que también lo veíamos
en costa rica allí teniendo muchas
dificultades por la saturación del
sistema hospitalario que dicen las
autoridades o hay un sub diagnóstico y
en realidad la situación es
completamente distinta que dicen
pues si bien algunos estudios refieren
que la cantidad real de muertos por
covite superaría por mucho a la cifra
oficialmente reconocida que es de 218
mil mexicanos que han perdido la vida lo
cierto es que se cumplen 4 meses con
tendencia sostenida a la baja tanto en
número de contagios como de muertos y
también en el ritmo de propagación del
virus el subsecretario de salud y
responsable ante la pandemia hugo lópez
gatell ha dicho que méxico libró una
tercera ola de kobe que se temía podría
darse después de la semana santa tan es
así que en la capital del país a partir
de este 10 de mayo
estamos en semáforo amarillo qué quiere
decir esto pues que habrá una mayor
reapertura los comercios y los cines por
ejemplo podrán operar al 40% de su aforo
y asimismo los espectáculos deportivos
al aire libre como por ejemplo los
partidos de fútbol en los estadios
podrán
abrir sus puertas con un aforo limitado
al 25% es una tendencia a la baja sin
embargo las autoridades llaman a no
echar las campanas al vuelo y a seguir
con las medidas de protección sanitaria
gracias mario por este completo reporte
desde la ciudad de mexico clara la
situación allí frente a la pandemia de
covite 19 demos ahora un vistazo a las
cifras de la vacunación como cierra esta
semana la región de américa latina en
términos de personas que han recibido al
menos una de las dosis el top 5 de los
países con más avance en la vacunación
lo lidera brasil con 31 puntos 50
millones de personas ya con al menos una
de las dosis recibirá le sigue canadá
con 13 puntos 73 millones de personas le
sigue méxico actualizamos la cifra con
13 puntos 33 millones de personas
argentinas está en cuarto lugar con 7.40
millones de personas ya inoculadas con
al menos una de las dosis este tope lo
cierra colombia con 3 millones de punto
45 millones de dosis ya lo decíamos
aunque el caso de este país es distinto
porque cierra la semana con por encima
de los 3 millones aunque la cifra debido
a la situación de orden público en este
país no ha sido actualizada por las
autoridades hasta el día de emisión de
este programa
y pese a liberar o liderar la vacunación
en la región brasil tiene uno de los más
altos ritmos de contagio a nivel mundial
es el segundo país con la mayor cantidad
de casos el país suramericano ya superó
los 15 millones de casos confirmados de
kobe 19 les doy la cifra exacta para el
cierre de esta semana 15 millones tres
mil 563 casos el estado de sao paulo que
es el más poblado de ese país tiene 46
millones de habitantes casi la población
de colombia está ubicado en el sureste
de brasil y sigue siendo la región con
más casos 2.9 millones y ya se aproxima
rápidamente a la barrera de los 3
millones de casos de contagio
y no es un secreto que la crisis
económica que se desató a raíz de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en el mundo entero
afectó la economía a nivel mundial chile
por supuesto no se escapa a esto y una
de las medidas para hacer frente a esta
crisis fue permitir que los ciudadanos
pudieran retirar parte de sus aportes de
los sistemas de pensiones un tercer
retiro ya fue avalado por las
autoridades los ciudadanos pueden
recibir hasta un 10 por ciento de esos
fondos pensionales para aliviar las
dificultades económicas veamos
largas colas durante todo el día en
chile frente a las oficinas de pensiones
este lunes comenzaba el proceso para que
hasta 10 millones de chilenos pudieran
retirar el 10% del dinero de sus cuentas
se trata del tercer retiro desde junio
del año pasado
justificado por la crisis que atraviesan
los ciudadanos debido a la pandemia soy
apasionado y lo retiro porque la plata
no alcanza con lo que saco de pensión
y con esa plata que estoy haciendo yo no
me alcanza por hecho retiro el de
proyecto el edil sobre de digno vivir
sobrevivir este tercer retiro se realiza
con la aprobación del parlamento pero
sin el beneplácito del gobierno de
sebastián piñera que vio como la corte
constitucional rechazó el recurso de
inconstitucionalidad que interpuso para
frenar la medida sin embargo genera
también controversia entre la población
muchas personas están atosigadas por las
deudas pero temen quedarse sin pensiones
en el futuro
no en vano en torno a tres millones de
personas ya se quedaron sin fondos
suficientes en febrero para este tercer
retiro
que cómo está la situación hay que saber
sacarlo
y le digo
yo creo que el estado debería darte una
pensión de gracias a los que no tienen
nada
y por qué no tiene tiene que saber
sacarle la discusión se enroca también
en torno al modelo de pensiones creado
en 1981 bajo la dictadura de pinochet y
que obliga a todos los trabajadores a
destinar el 10% de su salario a un fondo
de pensiones privado la principal queja
de los chilenos es el poco beneficio que
obtienen especialmente si se compara con
las ganancias que obtienen las seis
administradoras de pensiones oficiales
hablamos ahora de uruguay que es un caso
muy particular porque comenzó la
pandemia como un país líder en la lucha
contra el kobe 19 pero rápidamente pasó
a ser fuertemente afectado por el número
de casos y ahora lidera el escalafón
mundial de muertes diarias por kobe 19
en relación al tamaño de la población
uruguay registra 17.31 fallecidos por
cada millón de habitantes le siguen en
ese conteo macedonia del norte hungría
paraguay bosnia herzegovina y croacia a
pesar de esto también la vacunación está
avanzando relativamente rápido y pronto
de esos 3.5 millones de ciudadanos
uruguayos estarán inoculados
a ir hasta montevideo allí se encuentra
a karina dalmasso hasta la ciudad de la
costa para ser exactos quien tiene más
detalles de la situación allí en ese
país suramericano karina gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa y
comencemos por un panorama general de la
situación las cifras son poco
alentadoras en términos de fallecidos y
también las hospitalizaciones son altas
y el avance de la vacunación también es
bueno es muy contradictorio el caso de
uruguay
uruguay se encuentra por séptimo día
consecutivo como el primero en el mundo
por la cantidad de muertes de
coronavirus en relación a la población
en estos momentos también los centros de
cuidados intensivos se encuentran
ocupados en un 77% el 55 por ciento de
ellos atiende a pacientes con kobe 19
las autoridades sanitarias investigan
también el fallecimiento de cuatro
personas por coronavirus donde se ha
denunciado falta de asistencia a las
mismas el presidente de la república
luis lacalle pou reiteró que de esta
situación se sale con la libertad
responsable de la ciudadanía hasta el
momento se mantienen como medidas el
cierre de gimnasios y comercios libres
de impuestos en la zona fronteriza con
brasil las clases habían sido
suspendidas se reintegró a las aulas en
las zonas rurales y hay un cronograma
para que las clases vuelvan a ser de
forma presencial en las próximas semanas
asesor científico honorario que asesora
justamente al ejecutivo indicó que
recomendaba la presencialidad en las
aulas pero que también se debería de
tomar medidas por ejemplo para limitar
la movilidad durante la madrugada una
especie de toque de queda nocturno y
también recomendó el cierre de bares
restaurantes y otros comercios estas
medidas no fueron tomadas por el
gobierno en cuanto a la vacunación ésta
continúa avanzando constantemente
actualmente el 35 por ciento de la
población ya recibió al menos una dosis
sin embargo los científicos indican que
si se vacunan solamente las personas que
hasta hoy han pedido ser inmunizados no
se llegaría al inmunización de rebaño el
panorama en uruguay interesante karina y
viendo en perspectiva en la región
uruguay es un país bastante estable en
términos sociales si se le compara con
otros estados alrededor pero ha
comenzado
despertarse un leve malestar social la
pobreza también ha comenzado a
incrementarse en estos últimos meses
pese a esto la gestión del presidente
luis lacalle pou sigue siendo muy alta
frente al manejo de la crisis del cob y
19 que dicen allí las personas
actualmente en uruguay la pobreza subió
de un 88 por ciento a un 11.6 por ciento
más de 400 mil personas se encuentran
bajo la línea de pobreza esto quiere
decir que no pueden cubrir sus
necesidades básicas también en el año
2020 la economía descendió un 6%
aproximadamente el 25% de los
trabajadores recurrieron al seguro de
desempleo la cifra de afectados es aún
mayor dado a aquellos que están en la
economía informal del país varias
organizaciones no gubernamentales
indicaron que hay un déficit alimentario
importante donde se se provee
alimentación en ollas populares a más de
55 mil personas cada día mientras tanto
el gobierno indicó que duplicó la ayuda
social por medio de programas de
alimentación en lo que va del año
en relación a la aprobación de la
gestión del presidente luis lacalle pou
en las últimas encuestas indicó que éste
tenía una aprobación de su gestión de un
59 por ciento
una situación similar se vive también en
otros países de la región en términos
del incremento de la pobreza
karina para el cierre me interesa hablar
de esa decisión que tiene uruguay muy
similar a la de eeuu de comenzar a
vacunar a los adolescentes qué avances
hay en esos estudios que están
practicando allá en uruguay para empezar
ya a inocular los
luego del análisis de varios estudios
internacionales las autoridades
sanitarias uruguayas indicaron que van a
inmunizar a los menores de 12 a 18 años
de edad con la vacuna de facer el país
está comprando nuevas dosis que están
llegando semanalmente al país sin
embargo aunque la inmunización también
será parece rango de edad de forma
voluntaria primero se estará dando la
vacuna a facer a los mayores de 70 años
y también a los indigentes que duermen
en la calle luego de que esta rango
etario de mayores de edad estén
inmunizados es cuando se está dando la
posibilidad a los menores de edad
también con una intención de que se
logre llegar al 70 por ciento de la
población para alcanzar la denominada
inmunidad de rebaño
gracias karina por este completo reporte
desde ciudad de la costa muy cerca allí
de montevideo la capital en uruguay y en
nuestra sección en redes para el cierre
del programa veamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
destacó una comenzamos con esta
publicación del diario abc de españa una
noticia muy positiva para la región la
oms se da luz verde a la vacuna china
sino fan para su uso de emergencia dicha
vacuna muestra que tiene un 70 y 8.1 por
ciento de eficacia para los adultos
según los estudios clínicos hay que
destacar que esta es una de las vacunas
más ampliamente usadas en américa latina
chile colombia perú uruguay méxico entre
otros países han inoculado con éxito
esta vacuna china hablamos en el pasado
en este programa de ese estudio
realizado en chile que daba cuenta de
sus buenos resultados a lo largo de
estos meses en ese país suramericano
y con esto llegamos al final de este
resumen aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa recuerde en la emergencia
persiste se mantiene sigan cuidándose
allí en sus casas y en sus respectivos
países pueden seguir con la programación
de france 24 nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces
[Música]